get some thoughts from T fellow Texas
Republican Pat Fallon kind enough to
join us Congressman what do you make of
what your colleague is saying that it
it's going to take more than a show of
support it's going to take sort of
resting this from an Administration that
he claims isn't doing
anything well chip Roy is right in the
sense that the this Administration is
doing absolutely nothing you know
they're trying to punish Texas Neil for
uh for their refusal to enforce current
immigration law so what I'd love for
those governors to do is send us more
razor wire send US troops that'd be
great for uh your National Guard but
also send Republican Senators to
Washington if you don't already have to
let's get to because we have to but
buttress this Administration it's
absolutely insane this is not even a
crisis anymore Neil this is a cataclysm
all right there are a lot of lawsuits F
back and forth as you know congressman
and that isn't solving the problem as
much as just contining to litigate it so
where do you see the lawsuit part of it
going that's going to be very
interesting I mean I'm fascinated by to
see what comes with all this it's very
clear that you're breaking state law now
because the Texas legislature passed sb4
which makes it a State Crime to come
into the country illegally but that's
already a federal crime as well so when
you get to cringe whatever her name is
the the lying mouthpiece that works for
Biden saying that they're not it's the
law it's the law it's the law why
doesn't she open a book and read the law
because they are not enforcing it and
Neil the last two uh president
administrations at this point in their
tenure three years deep had just about
1.6 million illegal border Encounters
this administration had 8.5 million so
clearly something has changed and it's
Alejandro my orcus and Joe Biden at the
helm that's the that's the root cause of
this crisis all right well I mean you
obviously are passion and how you feel I
don't NE think it's necessarily true
that the White House Press folman is a
lying mouthpiece having said that though
I can understand your frustration I am
curious what happens on this border deal
that apparently you guys are quite close
on here and there's talk that Donald
Trump has advocated not endorsing it not
doing anything about it I don't know how
true that is but how do you feel about
that that he feels it would lock you
into an unpopular measure and something
that could actually hurt Republicans in
the fall what do you
think well what's interesting Neil is
Joe Biden has the executive authority to
solve this Cris right now cataclysm
whatever he can reinstitute the white
Mexico policy which president Trump so
brilliantly uh did in fact I was at the
border a couple weeks ago and we asked
all of the border patrol agents what's
the one thing if you could only do one
thing what would it beta really help
alleviate and mitigate this uh this
flood really of illegal migrants and
they said wait Mexico that will reduce
it by 70% Joe Biden can do that right
now without any Congressional Authority
he
he to reenact an executive order resign
executive order to undo his executive
order to undo what Donald Trump was
doing so you're right he does have that
power right now would that um solve the
problem right there or is it now much
more involved and this package that
they're
negotiating uh has some of the issues
that you want to address on the border
specifically there are some other issues
to address about Asylum cases that even
president Trump had acknowledged when he
was trying to deal with this it's out of
control and Congress must solve what do
you make of that no absolutely you have
to redefine credible fear I mean we're
uh there's Asylum claims from folks in
Venezuela that cross 89 different
countries just to get here they're
economic migrants they're not political
Asylum Seekers we know that the NOS are
really the TA American taxpayer money
goes to the NGL the NGL tell these folks
what to say and so we have to get the re
this in and you do that by uh expedited
removal you do it by wait in Mexico you
do it by redefining credible fear and
you do it by building walls barriers I
don't care what Joe Biden calls it but
we need to secure the border and you
need to we have no higher calling than
to protect American citizens that's
that's literally our constitutional Duty
and we're not doing that right now when
169 people that were on the terror watch
list were a hun at the southern border
the last year president Trump was in
office that number was three it went
from three to 169 and I could rattle off
figures and take up your whole hour but
the point is we've got to get this under
control because Joe Biden has been
sticking his head in Collective woke
sand for too damn long we'll watch it
very closely Congressman Pat Fallon good
seeing you again thank you sir thanks D
God bless hey everyone I'm Emily compano
catch me and my co-hosts Harris vulner
and Kaylee mcki on outnumbered every
weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or set
your DVR also don't forget to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights